construction
hello and welcome to our web talk making
the eu sexy
they you the european elections on
social media so in this hangout we'll be
talking about what candidates are doing
to make their campaigns more appealing
for voters on social media i'm japonic
below and i'll be your host for this
hangout and our guests today are the
following people we have rick mendez who
is with you watch in brussels and this
is an organization that is actually also
working on collecting all the tweets
related to the elections using the main
hashtag ep 2014. so hi rick
hello
hello
all right
we also have van niels henders man he is
a social democrat here in germany and he
hopes to be maybe part of the eu
parliament very soon hi niels hello
all right
uh next up is martin
an e an election analyst actually
sitting in hamburg uh how are you doing
martin
hi i'm fine i'm on
right
and then back to back in brussels we
have uh karolina wozniak who is a social
media editor with the eu parliament
hello karine carolina
hello
and last but not least of our guests we
have john worth an eu blogger and he
basically blogs about eu issues
including the elections
hi john hello from berlin
so because we want you guys to take part
in this hangout we will be expecting you
to tweet about it and maybe answer the
questions are these elections sexy
enough for you and you can answer that
using the hashtag dwebtalk on twitter
and we'll have our social media editor
anne sophie brendlin uh she'll be
looking at your comments on twitter
hi anne sophie hi that's right i'll be
looking at your tweets and i will erase
this awesome sign here if i have any
good questions from you guys and i'll be
sure to forward them to you
all right so this is promising to be a
rather exciting hangout i mean we're
talking about the eu elections something
that's supposed to affect everyone
living in europe and also the rest of
the world um but first up we have this
video
this is an ad
an ad tries to tell you
what to do
but this ad wants you to tell us what to
do
use that
power and choose who's in charge
vote from may the 22nd to may the 25th
european elections
may 2014.
that was a video from the eu
parliament's youtube channel and um i'd
like to ask all of our guests um was
that video appealing enough for voters
out there if you think it was appealing
please raise your arm
right so we have the
eu parliament itself carolina says yes
but the rest of our of our guests don't
think so so maybe i'll start with john
worth why would you say that wasn't
appealing for voters
i i think that's a little bit too harsh
obviously the european parliament has to
do that kind of public information
campaigning the difficulty is is how
many people are going to see such an
advertisement uh the amount of money
which is paid in in doing so i
understand why the european partner has
to make such films but i don't think
it's going to make that much difference
to how many people are actually going to
go and vote in the european elections
either positively or negatively martin
you also said no i mean you just heard
what john said uh would you agree with
his opinion and would you be able to
tell us what you think was wrong in that
video
i think the video is perfect it's very
cool style very cool stuff there inside
and the cool optic and and uh if i
like to see that um maybe it's
it's for me a motivation to go to a
white road but um i think a lot of the
european people don't see the video
because it's only a youtube account of
the uk parliament
on campaign account but nobody goes
there nobody goes to the account to look
at this video to watch the video and so
i think they don't reach there to keep
up with this video and so i think that's
not effects for the campaign for the um
uh for the people going to the boat
well martin if i would just interrupt
you i i was on youtube earlier today
watching another video and that ad did
appear so i think the eu parliament and
carolina you can correct me or not is
actually paying um youtube uh some money
i guess for people to see that ad is
that correct or is there some sort of
partnership
uh we are doing a promotion of the video
to make sure we reach people with it
it's not only in our youtube channel
it's also shown uh by different
broadcasters it's on our different media
channels uh social media channels on
twitter on google plus on facebook as
well because we try to reach with it as
many people as possible it exists not
only in english but in all languages
including some
for example
other languages like uh catalan
so we're trying to make sure that people
can understand the message in their own
language and we want to reach as many
people as possible but this is not the
only product that we have we have
specific products for example for young
people on other videos
yeah yeah sorry carolina it was just uh
it was just to set our conversation and
discussion going and maybe just to kind
of get a sense of what is being done out
there um i mean because if you compare
it to some of what maybe was done over
the weekend with eurovision you can't
compare in the amount of social media
activity going on with the eu elections
that compared to say something like
eurovision or even sports for that
matter so even if the eu does affect our
lives it seems people are not you know
really getting into it as much at least
not on social media anyway and maybe i
should turn to nils now um
what are you doing exactly as a
politician to engage your voters on
social media
well first of all uh i think that social
media especially for the european
elections has a lot of advantages
because it seems to that the european
level is a bit
further away from
the
real life of people and social media
helps to bring
our
policies
closer to the people um
and make decisions uh which are made in
brussels far away from the real life
sometimes
a bit more
interesting for people but it's hard and
you have to have followers you have to
have of course a facebook account
twitter account and so on
but i also see that there's um not that
much of interest if you are just
starting as a new candidate and not
being elected yet because it's hard to
find more than the normal people within
the party to join your facebook account
to join your um to follow you on on
twitter um but of course this is uh
the part of the campaign and to bring
more people to to listen what the ideas
of social democrats
are about and especially what my um
policy
will look like if i'm elected and
so this is this is the main task now in
the campaign to bring more people also
following me on social media yeah well
um it's interesting what you say because
obviously
it's a social democrat in germany um
rick mendez you are portuguese of course
you're sitting in brussels but i'm
assuming you are observing what's going
on in portugal as well do you think the
experience there is slightly different
from what's taking place here in germany
is the debate on social media
different or even how candidates are
interacting with uh voters
well um i i think the situation on
social media is very different on each
european country
not only social media in general but
also networks so for example some
countries will have a presence a natural
presence on facebook or other social
network much more elevated than twitter
uh twitter is still seen
in my opinion for
uh you know general people as a very
specific tool uh that has a reputation
to be targeted to journalists or
politics or
you know people that are in some way um
following very specific events like
sports events or political events but
very specific issues and uh i'm not sure
that there is the same amount of people
on twitter that there is naturally on
facebook um
so i think for portugal for example i
don't think that um
portuguese citizens are watching the
elections
via twitter
and since the national media are doing
in my opinion a very poor job on
reporting about europe not only the full
year the wall year and during the wall
uh you know the the the world
legislature um this is not happening uh
so suddenly there is the election and
suddenly national tvs have to do
something about it because otherwise you
have the kind of scandals like you have
in france of the public broadcaster not
uh not uh going through with the with
the
with the candidates about to the
european commission
on public tv so you have this kind of of
problems in different european countries
um
social media in some countries like
spain for example i would say
france spain and the english
in general are the the three more
presents
inside the ep 14 2014 hashtag now maybe
we should turn we should turn to john
worth because obviously you sort of have
a
an eu wide view and you are british
yourself so have you noticed a very
different debate going on in the uk i
mean of course the other is the
discussion of them maybe potentially
leaving the eu one day at least maybe
next year there might be a referendum so
um could just comment about what kind of
debate is it more intense and our
candidates actually also making use of
social media in a different way
yes the uk debate is extremely intense
it must be said um but it's not
necessarily very well informed or indeed
very well informed about the european
elections per se it's a wider debate
about kind of in or out of the european
union
and so that's the challenge in the uk is
that the debate is focused very very
strongly around britain's relationship
with the european union not the european
parliament elections itself
in terms of different countries and
their use of social media and how
candidates are using it twitter is very
very active in british politics and it's
much less active in german politics as i
see it from my own personal point of
view and this depends a little bit on
the development of each individual
country and other countries for example
like netherlands has extremely
interesting uh twitter environment in
politics um so it depends on the
individual national environments which
tools work best i think the advantage of
twitter for the european parliament
elections is it allows that
transnational debate to happen to a
certain extent an issues-based debate to
happen and having either of those things
on facebook is much much harder i think
the candidates that use facebook very
well are candidates that want a deep
engagement with their own party
supporters with their own people who are
kind of in their own environment already
and a deeper engagement with those if
you wish to debate something widely
across the entire political system then
that's uh where twitter comes into its
own um we have at least seen even in
environments where twitter has not been
so important until now denmark for
example some kind of increase in the use
of twitter in recent months partly
motivated by some candidates in the
european elections using twitter
intensively there
right well thanks um i just saw from ann
sophie that we have a comment or a
question from social media so and sophie
can you just tell us what that is yeah
actually we have quite a few comments
but one of them was about what uh niels
hindersmann said before that he's using
using more and more social media to
interact with
voters and we have one question let me
show it to you on facebook
um ivan burrow as eu politicians don't
interact on social media their interns
do it for them
so here's my question is that true or
are you actually posting yourself well
i'm posting myself i don't have an
intern i have people also to help me in
the campaign volunteers but um
they will also sometimes
post something on facebook but my uh
facebook page and my facebook account i
still um do my posts myself
right um maybe we should ask carolina
that as well because obviously you
your work sort of involves also
current meps some of whom may be
campaigning do you happen to know
whether most of the meps are using
facebook and twitter themselves or
whether they have a team doing that for
them
uh in our wardrobe we are the central
administrative accounts so we are not
doing any work for the meps they are
doing this on their own we know uh how
many of them are on twitter on facebook
but we don't know how they do it uh how
they organize their work so on this
question i cannot help you all right
well i i can tell uh that when we do
chats with them it's actually them
sitting and typing or talking with
people during their hangout
right um i don't know i mean obviously
maybe what we can go on to now is maybe
does any candidate who
is using social media in their campaign
very effectively is there any candidate
out there um martin do you know of any
candidate who is doing that
yes and john told uh in his comments
before that not so a lot of many jones i
use social media at its best and in the
campaign or any work as mep
and but one or two guys i like to
recommend and one is the young philip
allstate it's from the green party it's
very young guy i think is the youngest
mmp from germany as well
and he
has the the magic of social media and
then the culture behind because he uses
online and offline between and he's not
an offline guide to that youth and half
an hour a day the online things and then
23 hours
on the offline guy and if he knows if he
only online you have to be um
motivate the offline guys
and when he is on the offline um he went
he used us
as normally the online things and and
then here yes
his advantages he has on the um
security data
issues and and and so it's for him it's
more easier
to uh
be in the
social media things because he's a net
politician and so it's all of these net
political interested guys and
people
right
um so basically he does interact with
voters so i mean from what we see on the
like on different levels and different
countries i know it's really complicated
with the eu but um
in terms of candidates are they
interacting more or are they
broadcasting just their views and
policies and then you know they just
leave people to retweet that and do
whatever with that information um maybe
john you would be able to say what
you've seen and observed on the eu level
yes i think we're seeing different
patterns of development um i'd just like
to also add one other politician um
who's from uh from netherlands who's
very good at using uh using social media
that's a marichy shaka from d66 um a a
young politician who does who's already
a member of the european parliament who
does lots of work about eu foreign
policy uh she's very much worth
following i think there's also the case
that smaller political parties are maybe
better at this than larger political
parties in the main there are obviously
some exceptions but a lot of liberals
and greens are better in brussels than
than social democrats and uh and and
christian democrats
and what i think is very important to
say as well is if you've been
engaging with a politician over a period
of time in social media you can see
which ones are the honest ones and which
ones are the good ones versus which of
the ones are just doing public relations
on social media um i'd just like to
point out for example a bad politician
in brussels vivian redding the european
commissioner and we know that her
account has been tweeting at the time
she's been stood on her feet in the
european parliament and she didn't have
an iphone in her hand when uh when that
was being those things were being
written
so we can be pretty certain that's not
actually her now i think if you are
engaging with politicians on an everyday
basis you can see which of the sorts of
ones will be engaging and which ones are
less likely to to reply and answer to
you
and that's the individual user's
responsibility to work that out
what i think we're going to see after
the european mention is a higher number
of uh meps and indeed commissioners in
brussels are
social media the numbers were really
quite high if you compare the particles
of politics
i think you're getting some
sound
from your side i don't know
right
where this is coming from yeah maybe it
would be better to
commute let's see
if okay sorry um okay
better uh yeah okay perfect then we'll
just carry on now um i was just gonna
pick up from where john had left off of
politicians i like you had mentioned
something about parties which are newer
and younger using social media in a
different way and i was going to ask
this question to nils um you're a social
democrat one of the oldest parties here
in germany do you think there's less of
an incentive for a party like yours or
for someone in your party like yours
which has a
big member base here in germany to use
social media do you think that you don't
need to be on social media as much
because you know that you do have voters
in large numbers in germany
well we used to have more voters
especially national elections so that
means that we always try to find new
voters and of course mobilize
people
to every election
and
there is a change what we can observe
and this is why
also professional campaigners in our
party are now spending more money more
budget on social media and so on to
reach new target groups and to also
interact with them so that means that
also we understood that there is an high
potential and that we should use it a
lot bit more
and
but on the other hand we still have a
lot of members and of course also
voters um who are not so much online
and maybe it's also because they live
sometimes in rural areas where we don't
have all this access to um high-speed
internet and so on but they still expect
from a candidate that he or she is also
presenting herself in real life and is
going um to some
small village even and uh to present
himself and say okay that's me i'm
running for european parliament and this
and this are my bullet is my political
agenda um and
the day only has 24 hours so you have to
decide on where you spend your your uh
time resources rather on social media or
on real
activities with real
voters where you interact in real life
with them but on the other hand i know
that i have a lot of
followers also on my facebook webpage
and they also want to see from me uh
what i'm doing because they cannot be
present at every event taking place
during the campaign and so i mean you
have to combine and try to combine both
and um i'm very sure that that it's
important to reach also new uh target
groups and new voters who are more
affiliated to this uh social media right
um i was just going to ask you quickly
uh which one's more important social
media or the traditional campaign of
nils for you which one's more important
at this time because you are doing you
are campaigning at this moment so if you
just tell us one or the other which one
are you focusing more on
well it it's sort of balancing itself so
i would say it's it's 50 50. i mean i
really try to do a lot on facebook and
twitter but um
we'll probably say this in a few minutes
that my facebook account and my twitter
account could be used more and that i
could have more followers i know that
but um the situation is that it's just
me and some volunteers supporting me so
it's not that i have endless resources
and put on that so on the same time i
try to do and spend um
at least
half of the time on uh the professional
and campaign and and the campaign was
with the um yeah in the traditional way
so that's that's what's
where i would say i do 50 50. all right
and uh rick is that what you've observed
as well is it a 50 50 situation for most
people campaigning
it really really depends on the on the
political parties in my opinion you have
for example the smds have uh
it seems some good teams doing a good
job uh even at the european level so if
martin chooses going to italy or
different countries he will have
different teams uh you know really
working out on social media to to put
pictures to put contextual information
to what uh martin justice is saying so
you have um you know it's really
depending but i think it's uh it's uh we
are far from
the u.s
level where social media was for example
the the obama's campaign was a really uh
um a tool that was really really
important and data mining was also very
important here in europe i don't think
we have uh the the market i mean we
don't have the amount of citizens using
the the networks the same way in the us
so it's really something evolving i
think this one here is maybe an
investment for many politicians many
political groups to actually invest more
time and more energy on social media
because on the next election i think
it's going to be largely different from
what we have today
all right
um maybe we should kind of turn into the
last question because um
briefly maybe all of you could tell me
or maybe before we do that actually um i
think we have a comment from from social
media i'm sorry about that and was there
and i didn't see her but i have now and
uh and so if you can just tell us uh
what has been said or asked on social
media yeah we're getting a lot of
responses on the question whether
getting in touch with voters by using
social media is actually making them
more sexy um there is one comment on
twitter um by the uk epp that is saying
is an essential way for new parties like
connect with potential voters voters
and then
um we have
um
you and sophie
can you hear us fine
i can hear your phone can you hear me
give him a call for everyone else for
everyone else
we'll have some difficulty
okay
uh maybe
um
carolina your mics uh over here just
yeah okay answer we can carry on
sure okay so
i was just saying that we have a couple
of comments and one of them is by the uk
epp that is saying social media is an
essential way for new small parties like
us to connect with potential voters and
then on facebook we have a comment um by
yuri yakuzco who is saying nothing makes
them as in politicians more sexy than
being open and reasonable decisions and
then we have one comment that is saying
the opposite by nelson andres perez
rodriguez who's saying no in latin
america to interact with them is the
same as to interact with delegates
right uh maybe i'll just
take uh something out of those comments
uh from and sophie maybe does social
media make candidates appear more open
and transparent i this is just maybe
briefly if we could start with john yes
or no with maybe a very very very short
sentence added to that
yes if they do it themselves yes
and then uh carolina
uh i don't want to judge the candidates
but i can tell you that it's very
important for the parliament to make it
transparent and i think social media are
helping us with this
okay uh martin martin
uh mike mike yeah
yes
i think it's more
the best way to open the parliament and
and
the work of the politicians but i think
the trick is to have to understand the
culture behind social media and then
it's the best way for transparency
okay uh nils
yes i think that is it's having a high
potential to bring the european level
closer to the voters and the people
okay and finally we have rick
yep definitely i think it's uh it's good
if they do it themselves and if they are
present it's uh it's a it's great to
engage in more transparency
all right so it seems like doing it
yourself makes a huge difference because
obviously having interns or someone else
doing it on your behalf uh just makes
you look a little bit um not as
trustworthy as someone who's sitting
there and doing it on their own i do
have also one question um about how we
can make um
social media more appealing um at least
for in the in the eu because obviously
the comparison is always with the united
states and maybe a little a few other
countries which
like where social media is really
sort of taken the leap forward um what's
the one thing that you could do to make
social media more exciting for voters um
in these elections or in the next ones
because maybe
not way too soon to talk about that um
we'll start with um rick this time
well that's uh that's a
that was my idea two years ago was uh
how
european elections are coming and how
what can i do to first understand better
how it's working how europe is working
or the parliament is working and how and
what can i do because i'm a webmaster
and i work on the web what can i do to
engage with people and then to try to to
have people to engage with the different
accounts uh so that's
prince this is the principal reason why
i started the watch was it for really
trying to engage with people and trying
to really put you know uh common
information from common people at the
same level of of
of tweets that are coming from
recognized media institutions or meps or
or whatever so i wanted to to mix
opinions and uh for me this was
one way to do it so also engaging with
people is what you would say okay yeah
all right uh nils
i would i would absolutely agree um uh i
think that
all candidates should spend more
resources time resources on social media
to interact with their voters and
this is what i will also see as a main
task for my campaign and so i know that
i can improve there a lot and maybe we
see our things
go out on the 25th of may and
maybe i will improve also my social
media presence
then a bit more
all right martin
yes i think
talks about the right things and i think
it's the best to engage the two people
five or six days before the election is
i think it's very very hard
i think the the trick is that we have to
engage the people four years before the
election is and it's it's very hard now
for news because he's the first time as
candidate and but um if you are voted or
if you're elected then you have to start
with the social media engagement for the
next election you have to engage people
all the time and not only in the four
weeks before the election is
and i think that's the hardest thing to
engage in people not only in the
campaign times on the all the time if
you are a politician in any parliament
right so uh continuity is important um
and carolina what would you say what
would that be
i think we will uh continue working on
the fact that people uh to make people
aware of the fact that they can contact
us through social media that they can
ask a question they can send us a
comment and that we will respond
and as it was said previously it's not
only during the election time but also
afterwards
okay and john finally
wait a minute now i'm on muted now it's
good um no i would say that social media
can give everyday citizens a voice in
european union policymaking uh uh not
only at elections but also in between
times and so that's be that contacting a
member of the european parliament or
signing an online petition or blogging
about the things that do or do not work
in the european union so that's what
i've been doing now for a number of
years as a blogger about the eu is kind
of telling those stories what does and
does not work in the european union and
trying to get those
matters are important to me out to a
wider audience and to try to apply some
pressure to some meps
and social media allows me to do that so
i'd encourage anyone with an internet
connection to get involved blog tweet
post questions on facebook um because
your voice can be heard in brussels if
you're organized enough and determined
enough
all right um thank you for the final
words so you heard that if you want to
get involved
get onto social media and if you want to
get involved and talk to us get into on
social media and use that hashtag dw web
talk because unfortunately we have come
to the end of our hangout but we still
want to hear from you so do use the
hashtag to join us and i'd like to take
this moment to thank all of our guests
for joining us um we really enjoyed this
discussion um
for the rest of you out there like i
said join us again but you can also
visit our europe special on dw dot d e
slash europe 2014
um so hopefully we'll hear from you on
social media
thank you
thank you everyone
thank you
thanks